hello everyone my name is Tyler and just
speak up and hanging out with a lot of
people from the south so I kind of
picked up a drawl so y'all are gonna
have to be able to I'm trying to get rid
of it I'm trying to stop doing it but it
keeps coming back y'all it keeps coming
back just like you guys for some reason
a typical day and the life of tyler
oakley includes waking up getting online
staying online all day tumbling tweeting
facebooking and if it's a friday i try
to upload a video but i'm really bad at
like keeping on my schedule my vlog has
always been like a diary for me and so I
always try to stay true to that and
always talk about what's going on in my
life and use it as a way to like
chronicle what's happening because I've
been doing it for like six years and
it's kind of been like a scrapbook for
me um but sometimes nothing is going out
of my life so then i'll talk about pop
culture so i'll talk about one direction
or honey boo boo or whatever like I
could just go on a rant about and half
the time like I don't script anything I
just AM like okay let's like record for
30 minutes hope I have three minutes
worth of footage that I can put in a
video and somehow it seems to work I'm
not complaining but yeah it's a little
haphazard can we just take a moment to
look at Zane's face Jesus Christ the
hottest number undeniably the Zane he
drips sex he you know looks beautiful he
speaks like just speaking right to my
soul everything about him is just like
perfect the other boys are all cute or
handsome or like husband material but
like the hottest was a Darren Criss stop
it stop it stop it stop it stop it stop
it stop it the first time I met Darren
Criss I was hosting a red carpet live
stream for The Trevor Project which is
the leading national organization for
crisis and suicide prevention for LGBT
youth so I was hosting the live stream
so it was like one hour into the live
stream and I'm just like chug along
doing interviews well I like having fun
and then I see him across the room in
like my stomach drops my heart drops I
like it starts so wedding for a few Slee
because I'm like this is the moment this
is my now
and he is like waltzing over slowly and
then it's like in between interviews and
I'm like to we like pull him over like
we because like we were waiting for
producers to like tell us diplomat Baba
and he came over and like we hugged and
we just chatted and I kept sharing
moments cuz like there were people at
home watching so I kept looking at the
camera being like because like I knew
people were watching the long and then
like yeah so it was like a whirlwind and
like I didn't even remember any of it
after it happened yeah it was magical
have fun tonight so what are you re i'm
looking at like dying I'm dying i can't
i first started on YouTube back in two
thousand seven I had seen william sledd
who was this really prominent he was in
the top five most subscribed back then I
thought he's just so funny just talking
to a camera and I had never seen
anything like that before and I was like
huh I could do that and at the same time
I had gone off to college and had just
kind of said goodbye to a lot of my
friends from high school so this was
kind of also a way for me to keep in
touch with them then I kind of saw that
more people were watching and I I
remember one time there was a hundred
views on a video and I'm like I don't
have a hundred friends so I was like
there must be other people by digging my
videos back in the day I interviewed to
work at Google and I had like five
interviews they said no and I cried and
cried and cried and I'm so thankful that
I didn't get it now because had I done
that my life would have been completely
different so I'm really thankful that a
lot of the jobs i applied for back in
the day never really panned out were the
ones that i did i ended up not liking
because he led me on to try to do
full-time youtube in though that's what
i get to do so it all worked out do you
know the word kiki is it like kinky no
wait a bit person no uh so a kiki is a
party that you have with your best
friends so like a little it could be
like a slumber party it doesn't have to
be a slumber party but it could be a
slumber party yes we gaze I have a Kiki
no you can have a Kiki no I won't have
you can have a kick it you can have a
gay but you know that's the phrase let's
have a Kiki I am going to have a total
Kiki um I will have I probably do like a
big twitcam I always do quick to cams
and most youtubers when they do like a
live show it's like an hour I can like I
had a set up camp
a whole bunch of bottles of wine order
Chinese stay online for like five hours
four hours I might do something like
that but i already have planned what I'm
gonna do for my million subscribers
video so I'm ready it's been like in the
making what was your first impression of
each other I don't even know how to
describe it I thought you hated me mmm
yeah the first time we contact each
other me and Kingsley was probably on
Twitter um which is how I kind of meat
every youtuber usually it starts with
like a flirty tweet and then like we
kind of go back and forth and this is
with everybody not just Kingsley and
then our audiences like freaked out and
ship us and then we're like I guess we
should make videos together and that's
usually how it goes with everybody but I
remember with Kingsley it boggled my
mind that even knew who I was because
like Kingsley's just like this legendary
youtuber um like super original like one
of a kind like he's been around forever
and he does his own thing so like for
him to even know who I was let alone and
like like me I was like oh my gosh we're
talking about doing another one so stay
change because that's what we do that's
what we do what is it stalking each
other this is the black people like
Thomas word ok this is what pitbull does
yeah it's like the worldwide when I was
younger if I knew that there were like
people on YouTube talking about their
lives or the coming out experiences like
I would have totally been all over that
so I feel like the more people that are
on YouTube that are you know openly
themselves whether it's lesbian gay
trans bisexual whatever the better
because like people can google that and
safely learn more about you know how
they identify or try to like relate to
somebody so it's really important to me
because like I completely understand
that I'm not everybody's cup of tea but
as like somebody who has a bit of
influence I feel like it's a lot of
responsibility on me to promote LGBT
youtubers that are completely different
than me so that if you don't get me
maybe you'll get one of the people that
is completely different than me that I
support we're those saying that it gets
better it didn't get better for you
without others on your side and it's not
gonna get better for those fighting
today without your help I would say like
projects like it gets better say that
YouTube is a space that's safe for
people even though like it gets a bad
rap with like all the comments section
and
like whatever you know negativity is
happening on YouTube there's a lot of
safety that you can find in the
community on YouTube and it kind of like
opens the door of dialogue that anybody
can get on YouTube anybody can get
involved anybody can have a voice and
anybody can influence other people it's
a level playing field where we all have
our own stories that are worthwhile
whether you have a million subscribers
or one subscriber your story is
worthwhile and I think that's what it
gets better shows over time as you are
more honest and open about who you are
it just gets easier and easier and I
promise you although it's probably
daunting it gets easier the future of
YouTube I don't know I have this
conversation with a lot of youtubers a
lot of times we always say like back in
two thousand seven eight nine like we
didn't know how long it was gonna last
and it's lasted this long so I feel like
I am just here for the ride having fun I
am everywhere on the internet like
tumblr Twitter Instagram Facebook very
prominent and I do more interactions
probably on all the other things than on
YouTube itself so heaven forbid if
YouTube were to crash in some capacity
I'd be fine because my people know where
to find me so it's not the end of the
world for me
I feel like I've grown up and I'm like
not even barely done with growing up so
I don't know like I can go back and
watch videos from 2007-2008 and I'm like
who is this child talking into a camera
um it's really interesting because it
I'm a completely different person now in
every video I'm completely different and
I'm a hundred percent okay with that
it's really interesting especially
because a lot of people are like oh
they'll say to their favorite youtubers
like oh you've changed the style of
videos you make has changed or you're so
different now or I wish you would make
this type of video that you used to make
back in the day but it's like I feel
like that's doing a disservice to giving
them the chance to be human and giving
them the chance to grow and evolve and
find themselves and be themselves and
I'm really fortunate I feel that my
audience is like go with the flow well
whatever I put up they'll be like okay
I'll work with this so if I'm like just
wrapping Nicki Minaj they'll be like yes
I want to preside get that or if I'm
like talking about my day they're like
okay or if I'm talking about one
direction like they're like okay so
anything that I do I feel like my people
are very supportive of what are we doing
today Marcus we are going to be
predicting future roads literally not
what we're doing it oh ok so we are
gonna be saying who I'm YouTube that
makes videos is the most likely to
dont't ah fill in the blank all-time top
five glozell has to be one of them she's
just iconic dailygrace what the buck
Jack and Finn I didn't want to like say
anybody else cuz then I'm excluding
everyone else um Kingsley miles Jai iton
say more than five like mamrie hannah
hart the vlog brothers like i'm a fan of
everybody like just as much as people
might be a fan of me like I wouldn't my
favorite youtubers post a new video I
have to drop everything and watch so
that's very much a part of me and I
can't I can't pick five I love with
everyone thank you for watching my
interview with new meteor rock stars if
you liked this interview push the like
button and subscribe to see more
interviews of your favorite youtubers
and if you want to see the full
interview go to New meteor rock stars
com the link will be below it we got the
whole interview and we
got a little photo shoot and I'm looking
adorable so go check that out okay bye i
am going to VidCon i am going to summer
in the city i am going to New York in a
couple weeks for a little project that
will be fun and big and then I'm going
straight to London for a few weeks to
work on a lot of collaborations I'm
going to Australia at the end of the
year um with another youtuber for
another like collaboration project so
I'm very busy this year and I feel
really fortunate that I get to travel a
lot and kind of go frolic around the
world and have fun and film in my life
and document it and put it on youtube
and that's what I do so this year is
going to be nuts so yeah a lots going on